this video is brought to you by nope
[Music]
what's up everybody michael here for a p
soaked quick take on south park's the
streaming wars part two as expected this
chapter of the streaming wars made us
laugh butter spiders my eyes are up here
stop staring at my throw up in our
mouths a little bit
and speculate about the marital dynamics
of man bear pig and pig bear girl but is
there something deeper going on beneath
all the urine jokes and can a
piss-filled water park in a
drought-ridden south park teach us about
how businesses function in times of
crisis let's find out in this wisecrack
quick take can fake boobs save the
planet and of course spoilers ahead but
before we dive in i want to tell you
about this week's sponsor jordan peele's
new film knope is out on july 22nd and
honestly we cannot wait both get out and
us operate in a long tradition of using
genre fiction to discuss the black
experience in america nope takes this
trend and does a left turn towards
science fiction now in us people explore
double consciousness the idea that black
identities are fractured to fit the
various roles they're expected to play
in a racist society now get out shows
the limit of a liberalism that is only
skin deep it successfully interrogates
the fetishization of black people and
the way that many are willing to
just use them for their own ends whether
they be political or simply for
entertainment now knowing that peel is
such a master of using genre to explore
big ideas we cannot wait to see how he
uses sci-fi to blow our minds even
further and all of us are super excited
to get out and see nope in theaters on
july 22nd and now back to the show in
our last south park video we explored
how the streaming wars uses water supply
or lack thereof as both a literal plot
point about environmental crises and a
metaphor about the state of today's
streaming economy unsurprisingly this
threat continues into part two because
matt and trey clearly still feel very
aggrieved by their 900 million dollar
deal with paramount plus it's not my
fault streaming services pay people more
than was sustainable in any business
model anyway part one ends with our
sweet mom and pop streamers randy and
tolkien's dad steve being wiped out by
the biggest streamer of all pee-pee
who's gonna solve south park's water
scarcity problem by becoming a baron of
recycled piss also any italians watching
let us know in the comments if pp is a
racist character or if you can even have
a racist representation of italians i
don't know let us know in the comments
when you're done eating your meatballs
after all the city's very thirsty
residents have no other option oh and
cartman still has massive fake boobs in
part two pp returns with a kingdom of
monetizable piss and he has big dreams
for his wee-wee water slides to supply
south park with enough pee for every
faucet popsicle mold and pasta pot in
the land in the absence of water urine
has become an abundant affordable
resource and pp controls it all it's a
perfect example of how the market can
find ways to profit off of just about
anything in this instance pp is using a
real problem affecting the life and
health of a community a drought to
create a great business opportunity for
himself and the show is clearly pointing
out that this happens all the time in
the real world just ask anyone who
bought stock and moderna and pfizer in
the spring of 2020 which i don't know if
that makes you a bad person but it felt
weird it felt weird when people did that
according to scholar david harvey crises
shake our mental conceptions of the
world and are placing it to the very
core and we as restless participants and
inhabitants of this new emerging world
have to adapt through coercion of
consent to the new state of things in
other words crises are a great
opportunity for those with power to
rework things for their benefit and we
see this in matt damon's favorite hobby
cryptocurrency trading which south park
continues to roast while it might not be
as exploitative as holding water
supplies hostage lots of folks without
money to spare have lost ridiculous
amounts buying crypto and celebrity
written ads for crypto are clearly
playing into current economic anxieties
and while crypto is a good example this
is just what the market economy does in
general namely finds a way to profit off
human necessities food housing medicine
while creating desire for things we
don't need multiple streaming services
speculative currencies fake boobs for
our moms and damon is back for the
streaming wars part two and this time he
and his celebrity friends are getting
paid so much that they're willing to
drink recycled piss it's shockingly not
too far off from reality recently fellow
influencer kim kardashian has told
interviewers she'd eat her own [__] if
it would keep her looking young i drink
my own piss and it keeps me looking old
um
of course these celebrities can endorse
things like cryptocurrencies because
their finances are already good to go
it'll be the naive consumer who risks
their financial future on crypto just
because matt damon told them that
fortune favors the brave fortune favors
the brave
at least when you buy jennifer lopez
indoor shampoo it's not going to ruin
your retirement plan but instead of
focusing on crypto this episode dives
into the depths of pp's piss palace
which exists solely because he took out
the other streamers to give himself a
stranglehold over south park's water
exacerbating an environmental crisis to
help turn a public good water into
profitable business and now he's poised
to make bank by selling people's piss
back to them this is what writer and
activist naomi klein calls disaster
capitalism orchestrated raids on the
public sphere in the wake of
catastrophic events combined with the
treatment of disasters as exciting
market opportunities and peepee is far
from the first person to spin shitty
situations into major coins america has
pulled a much larger version of pp's
move in several south and central
american countries that is somebody who
has helped plan coup d'etat yeah not
here but you know other places like
chile where they helped the military
carry out a violent coup in 1973 on
behalf of augusto pinochet who would go
on to rule with stunning brutality after
the coup milton friedman and his
acolytes from the chicago school of
economics helped install a shiny new
free market economy still reeling from
political violence chile had the perfect
conditions for what friedman called
economic shock treatment fearful of
communism and eager to exploit economic
opportunities in countries like chile
america repeatedly backed military
regimes that privatized public
industries turning public wealth into
private profit and rest assured american
corporations saw plenty of money to be
made in these new markets and yet the
actual economic results were
catastrophic as klein writes chile's
economy shrank 15 in the first year of
shock therapy while unemployment grew
from three percent to a staggering 20
and america used this same playbook
during the war on terror according to
klein the bush administration used the
trauma of 911 to exploit all the
economic opportunities that come with
decades-long wars they essentially
launched a new economy because the
parameters of this economy were
extraordinarily wide this is an endless
war we were told that the enemy could
not be reasoned with could not there
could be no diplomacy there could be no
discussion there could only be attack
and that it would not end until evil was
defeated everywhere right so if you
think of it as a business plan it could
hardly be more profitable because
basically what you're saying is you've
got this new market
it's never going to end
and we have unlimited funds
to finance this this new market and in
the case of pp's empire we've got shock
and a seemingly limitless market so what
can we do when faced with the
overwhelming forces of disaster
capitalism klein generally concludes
that when unfettered private markets
control society it can empower bad
actors and no she doesn't mean gwyneth
paltrow and that to counter this we need
both greater regulation of industry and
an economy where certain industries and
infrastructures are publicly owned where
certain human needs are not subject to
the whims of the market but guaranteed
rights to everyone and a world where in
the face of disaster rather than
predatory capitalist descending the
devastated communities themselves are
empowered to rebuild we see this happen
to some extent when randy stops being a
karen and decides to re-embody who he
used to be a talented scientist who's
uniquely qualified to solve south park's
water problem and after some public
cajoling and a massive deck he gets the
local government to pour money into his
ocean water desalination project after a
few less relevant plot points randy
eventually finds the solution to the
town's water problem in cartman's
distractingly huge boobs how to get salt
water to the desalinization plant
salt water saline
saline
in the plant saline implant holy and at
first glance it seems like they simply
found a barstool sports friendly answer
to their problem it's sort of like ads
from power companies asking us to use
less power during the hottest months
somehow if those in charge can't seem to
manage their massive power grid it
becomes our individual responsibility to
keep things running during peak demand
we didn't cause these problems we can't
really fix them but we are asked to take
on the responsibility of making things a
little less bad individuals are asked to
sacrifice while governments and
corporations keep it business as usual
if this sounds like a discouraging
bummer it is and we see this defeatism
at the end of the special we have enough
water for the summer now [__] it let's
smoke some
the group decides it would be too much
of a hassle to kill chuck chuck and
therefore solve climate change forever
and they know it'll take a lot more than
an army of saline filled double d's to
truly mitigate large-scale drought but
it's like hard work so why not enjoy
ourselves a little bit before we all
become dried out raisins but what do you
think have south park streaming wars
shown us the depraved depths of disaster
capitalism or is this just a fun 50
minutes of urinal humor let us know in
the comments thanks to our patrons for
all their support and don't miss out on
our new patreon perks they're very good
also join us for our weekly live stream
every thursday right here at 11am
pacific be sure to like this video hit
the subscribe button ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching i'll see
you later
[Music]
you